for the daily cancellation today i must
sadly cancel many of you in the audience
for your involvement
in a totally disgraceful and
disappointing display over the weekend
it all began when rumors started
circulating online
that president biden tragically pooped
his pants while visiting with the pope
in rome amy tarkanian a political
strategist and pundit was one of the
first to make this odorous allegation
tweeting quote the word around rome is
that biden's meeting with the pope was
unusually long because biden had a bit
of a bathroom accident at the vatican
and it had to be addressed prior to him
leaving i know we joke often about this
but this is the actual rumor going
around rome now
next thing you know
hashtags like hashtag poop gate and
hashtag poopypants biden and the more
direct hashtag bidenshispans were
trending nationwide on twitter
other sources were you know chiming in
all claiming that yes joe biden did
indeed drop a steamy load in his pants
right in front of pope francis
and then millions of other people
with no special knowledge about the
situation people with no specific
insights into joe biden's defecation
habits at all frankly still we're
posting about the subject spreading this
insidious rumor
and to once again clarify by insidious
rumor i am referring to the claim that
joe biden pooped himself at the vatican
that's the rumor
and personally i'm outraged and
disgusted by all this
it is the absolute height of your
responsibility to spread rumors of this
sort
there is no legitimate reason to call
attention to the issue of joe biden
hitting himself no reason
someone has to be the mature one in this
situation and as usual that job has
fallen to me which is why i am not
talking about the subject of joe biden
soiling himself
i would never talk about something so
crass and objectionable and
unsubstantiated we don't even know if
joe biden really did poop his pants
there's some people saying he pooped his
pants others saying that he didn't poop
his pants
still there are others saying that we
have no idea what joe biden did or
didn't do in his pants
in the face of this uncertainty
the dignified and honest thing is to say
nothing at all
i am therefore begging all of you to not
talk about this
and if you didn't know about it until
you just heard about it right now
don't talk about it
it's not the kind of thing we should be
discussing which is why i have
personally chosen to do my part by not
calling attention to it at all it's
better if the public never even hears
about this rumor
the rumor that joe biden president
united states pooped himself so please
once again
just don't talk about it in fact shortly
before we went on air i noticed another
hashtag associated with the poopypants
predicament a large number of social
media users have apparently caused the
hashtag shartweek to trend
this is not only potential
misinformation but it also makes light
of the trauma suffered by actual shark
attack victims
and actual shark attack victims
that's why i would never extend this pun
by saying that the vatican became
something of a shark tank when biden
arrived
that's a joke i'm not going to make
there are many other presidential poop
jokes that i will not make
and would be very angry to hear anyone
make for example i'm not going to say
that through his eight years as vice
president biden apparently got
accustomed to being the number two guy
in the white house i'm not gonna say i'm
not gonna say that biden flew back from
rome in air force two i'm not gonna say
that involuntary defecation must be a
hereditary problem for biden since it
runs in his genes
these would be vulgar and unfunny jokes
and i'm not gonna make them or any other
because there's nothing funny about a
turd
especially a turd in the pants of the
president
allegedly
now all we know for sure
the only thing we should be saying about
biden's visit with the pope
is that he went there in his official
capacity as a president united states
and he did his duty
that's it
outside of that our responsibility is to
comport ourselves with maturity and
dignity and respect the office of the
presidency and we should still respect
the office even if that man in that
office happens to have evacuated his
bowels right into his underwear
you know i don't care if biden did have
a literal holy [ __ ] moment in front of
the pope that doesn't change anything
except his diaper
as for the rest of us we have to be
adults about this
and the fact is that many of you have
failed in that regard you have used
biden's poo filled pants as a forum for
jokes and mockery rather than gazing
upon them in solemn silence as is your
duty and his apparently allegedly does
it make sense that the same company who
controls half of online retail also
passively eavesdrops on your private
conversations at home big tech is more
powerful than most countries are and
they profit by exploiting your personal
data it's time to put a layer of
protection between your online activity
and big tech and that's why i use
expressvpn think about how much of your
life is on the internet sadly every site
you visit video you watch message you
send gets tracked and data mined but
when you run expressvpn on your device
the software hides your ip address
something bigtech can use to personally
identify you so expressvpn makes your
activity harder to trace and harder to
sell to advertisers therefore expressvpn
also encrypts 100 of your internet data
to keep you safe from hackers and
eavesdroppers that are on your network
what i like most about expressvpn is how
easy it is to use you can download the
app on your phone or computer tap one
button and that's it you're protected
expressvpn does all this without showing
or slowing down your connection that's
why it's rated the number one vpn
service by techradar the verge and
countless others so
stop handing all of your personal data
over to the big tech monopoly who minds
your activity and sells your information
protect yourself with the vpn that i
trust to keep me safe online visit
expressvpn.com walsh yt to get three
extra months free
in a stunning display of courage a white
british tick-tock influencer has
revealed to the world that he identifies
as korean ali london is his name he's
been getting plastic surgery for several
years in an effort to as a newsweek
article puts it resemble their k-pop
idol jimin of bts
i have only a vague idea what any of
those words mean but the upshot is that
now london who also identifies as
non-binary has completed his surgical
transition and is ready to fully live
his life as the gender fluid korean that
he's always been deep down for too long
he has had a korean trapped inside his
body and now
with 150 000 of assistance from cosmetic
surgeons his true east asian self has
emerged like a bruised and swollen
butterfly from a fleshy cocoon
in a video recorded just after his
latest procedure ali explains that his
surgically adjusted eyes and nose and
other features now confirm
uh confirm him as a tried and true
korean and i think the case that he
makes is pretty bulletproof
let's listen
hey guys i'm finally korean i've
transitioned
i'm so so happy i've completed my look
i'm finally korean guys i have the eyes
just had a brow lift as well
um so i'm so happy finally i've been
trapped in the wrong body for eight
years
and that's the worst feeling in the
world when you're trapped and you don't
feel like you can be yourself but
finally i'm korean i can be myself
and i'm so so happy
he looks happy
finally he is korean it's as simple as
that
bigots might voice disagreement
insisting that one must actually be from
korea or at least have korean
citizenship in order to be considered in
any sense korean
they might even argue that surgically
narrowing your eyes to resemble asian
facial features not only fails to make
you asian but is also highly insulting
and degrading to the real asians of
which you are not one but ali definitely
countered these arguments in a series of
tweets disarming and debunking such
discriminatory talking points he wrote
quote
being transsexual is the same as being
transracial because you're born in the
wrong body
in other tweets he announced that quote
trans rights are human rights and that
quote there are millions of
underrepresented trans-racial people in
the world and i want to elevate their
voices and help them live their truth
and be themselves
now these may be more assertions than
arguments more spitting slogans than
making a case
but if if that's been sufficient for
transgender advocates then why shouldn't
work for a trans-racial pioneer
driving the point home ali i think
really vanquished his critics once and
for all
by dropping the ultimate progressive
trump card in a different video listen
this is my reason for sharing the flag
and i do identify as korean this is my
choice this is my decision it's not
hurting anyone
there you go
his decision his choice not hurting
anyone
that's really it right in the age of
psychological man when all that matters
is an individual's mental states and all
that you must do to justify an action is
claim that the action makes you feel
good and causes no direct physical harm
to anyone else whether or not the latter
is actually true the validity of a white
man's transformation in that context
into a genderless korean cannot be
denied
certainly if you accept trans ideology
then you have absolutely no logical
basis for denying ali's truth a truth
which is grounded in the exact same
premise
a truth which must indeed be true if the
premise is true
and the premise to remind you
is that a person's physical biological
identity is totally determined
by how they feel about
themselves a man who feels like a woman
is not merely a feminine man but is
actually a literal woman
all of the physical barriers which have
for millennia serve to separate men from
women are dissolved and discarded
biology is subordinated to the emotional
whims of the individual
why should ali's emotional whims not be
afforded the same supernatural weight
his case
based on the logic of progressivism is
airtight
based on the logic of
well logic it's not at all but based on
the logic of progressivism it is
and yet the left has not accepted him
comments on the internet about his
racial transition have been
overwhelmingly negative the daily wire
documents a few of them reading now it
says i'm sorry but you can't just choose
to be korean it's a nationality and
ethnicity tweeted one trans-identifying
account
you have to be born korean just because
you like the culture doesn't mean you
can take it and become it
there is a way to appreciate a different
culture this is not it
quote as a korean non-binary person i
haven't really talked about the ali
london thing but the fact that they're
acting like it's genuine that it's part
of a journey due to an identity issue
really irks me it's a mockery of trans
people it's cultural appropriation
posted another person finally one korean
user replied that while he celebrated
london's new gender identity it's wrong
for him to claim a new ethnic identity
korean isn't a pronoun nor is it a
persona you decide to suddenly take on
because of k-pop hype
i'm glad you identify as non-binary and
i applaud you for being transparent
about that but i can't commend you for
taking a whole ethnicity and treating it
like a persona
hmm
taking a whole ethnicity and treating it
like a persona
almost like
when someone takes a biological sex and
treats those i don't know an article in
the left-wing paper mag written by
sandra song editor-at-large and a fellow
korean
is just one long transphobic harangue
against the entire trans-racial
community song writes quote
as someone who actually has korean dna
though
i can say that some white fetishists as
proven by those 15 surgeries to look
look like jimin
suddenly deeming themselves korean is
incredibly offensive especially since it
effectively trivializes our identities
because they're suddenly trendy
apparently though that doesn't really
register for ali who's continually been
a notable example of western
fetishization that's
objectified us based on south korea's
recent contributions to global culture
so yeah obviously it's pretty sus that a
white person is tr is saying they're
korean
now leaving aside the embarrassing fact
that the magazine's editor at large
wrote and published the words so yeah
and pretty sus
the real problem is that she would
accuse a person of fetishizing
and trivializing her identity simply
because he is cartoonishly mimicking her
appearance and claiming that his
degraded mockery is as authentic as her
own identity i mean she's essentially
arguing that his imitation
is an imitation and thus cannot be as
valid or real as the thing he is
imitating
and her points make a lot of sense
come to think of it but unfortunately
she like nearly everyone else in her
ideological camp has already thrown open
the doors and invited men to fetishize
and trivialize and mimic her identity
it's just that she wishes the mimicry
would stay contained to her sex not her
ethnicity
the problem though
is that sex is far more objective
and far less fluid than ethnicity
if the former can be erased
then so can the latter ali london knows
that
and now he's entitled to be seen as
fully korean just as korean as any other
korean indeed he may be even more korean
than cis koreans like sandra song
i mean you can make that argument
this at least was a choice uh that he
has made
bravely
if cis koreans don't want to tolerate or
accept trans koreans that's their
problem and their bigotry they have to
work through
it'd be better for them to just remain
silent in the meantime while the march
of progress continues and all objective
markers of identity are erased and human
existence is reduced to a murky puddle
of ambiguity
that is the world the left wanted and
now they have it
congratulations